so then we decided to go to a fertility
clinic
which side note the fertility clinic is
all comedians there's like one in New
York they're like you're comedians too
and you look over it looks like a green
room at the Funny Bone it's just like a
row of 40 year old female Comics like
hey
oh just a bunch of [__] uh you know
Comics that trying to make it so you put
everything off but anyways we went and I
have something I never know how to
pronounce this it's varicose veins in
your balls okay like the back of your
ball but if you look it up it literally
says it looks like a bag of worms my
ball bag is
appalling it's really just the backup
just the back yeah the front front
gorgeous yes beautiful you can eat off
these balls
the back the back it looks like you know
your grandmother's legs
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
thank you